buongiorno sono traver spiga sono una
ricercatrice grossetana sono un
biochimico e lavoro presso l'università
di siena
oggi sono qui non posso né molto caro il
giardino dell'archeologia accanto alla
fondazione polo universitario grossetano
quello di cui vorrei parlarvi è
l'importanza che hanno le risorse
naturali per l'uomo e ad esempio l'aria
l'acqua e i minerali sono infatti
importanti per la nostra vita ma possono
terminare perché sono delle risorse
limitate questo innanzitutto perché
l'uomo tende a consumarle molto
velocemente ed in secondo luogo perché
tendiamo a sprecarle un esempio molto
semplice è proprio quello dell'acqua ma
anche i minerali con cui costruiamo gli
oggetti e materiali di cui siamo
abituati ad essere circondati e da ad
utilizzare presso potremmo non averli
più cosa dovremmo fare quindi bisogna
iniziare a comportarci come fa la natura
stessa quindi seguendo un ciclo per la
natura infatti nulla è un rifiuto nulla
finisce in discarica in natura tutto ciò
che per noi appare uno scarto qualcosa
cioè che non serve ed è da buttare
costituisce una risorsa per altri essere
viventi o per la natura stessa nei
nostri libri di scienze possiamo vedere
come una pianta fresca grazie ai
nutrimenti contenuti nel terreno
si sviluppa muore per costituire nuovo
bus sul quale nuove piante nasceranno e
il ciclo si ripete all'infinito
l'uomo fino fino ad oggi si è comportato
in un altro modo cioè seguendo quella
che viene realta modalità di procedere
lineare prendiamo le materie prime le
trasformiamo in un oggetto in un
materiale e quando questo si consuma o
non ci serve più lo buttiamo e così
produciamo uno scarto che quasi sempre
anche un'azione inquinante e fa male al
nostro pianeta
come facciamo quindi a capire se un
oggetto inquina e quanto inquina se un
rifiuto che non possiamo rigenerare in
qualche modo questo tipo di approccio è
possibile attraverso un determinato tipo
di analisi cioè la valutazione del ciclo
di vita di un oggetto della materia e
grazie a questo metodo che possiamo
seguire tutti i passaggi dalla
produzione di un oggetto fino al suo
utilizzo finale che noi facciamo ogni
giorno quando un prodotto raggiunge la
fine del ciclo di vita
nell'economia circolare le risorse
restano all'interno del nostro sistema
economico in modo da poter essere
riutilizzate più volte
questo perché non si deve buttare via
niente
quando per fare economia circolare si
usano delle risorse biologiche
provenienti dalla terra e dal mare si
sta parlando di economia circolare un
esempio ce lo da il famoso sacchetto di
plastica che ormai è costituito da
biomateriali ed è riciclabile
ma anche molte sostanze usate per
esempio per farmaci cosmetici o alimenti
sono oggi costituiti con un approccio di
bio economia
niente finisce per davvero e tutto
diventa qualcos'altro
sono sempre di più le idee sul nostro
sul nostro territorio in cui si
utilizzano degli scarti da riutilizzare
un esempio è quello fatto in sicilia
sulle arance in cui le bucce venier
vengono utilizzate attraverso un
approccio biotecnologico per costruire
costituire dei filati
un altro esempio è invece quello della
buccia del riso che viene utilizzata per
costruire dei materiali di bio materiali
resistenti alle alte temperature
naturalmente tutto ciò di cui vi ho
parlato a un determinato importo sul
territorio e sul pianeta in cui viviamo
ed è proprio su questo territorio sono
infatti di svolgimento progetti inerenti
utilizzo di biomateriali uno scarto e di
rifiuti derivanti da due filiere
produttive legate alla realtà
imprenditoriale monale sto parlando
nello specifico d'origine la castagna
del monte amiata e delle alpi fossati
della laguna di orbetello entrambi
rappresentano in ottica di economia
lineare uno scarto o un vero e proprio
rifiuto che deve essere conferito in
discarica costituendo in questo modo un
costo per i produttori e per le
amministrazioni locali nel caso del
riccio della castagna del monte amiata
castagna igp si tratta di uno scarto con
valore pressoché nullo che anche nelle
stagioni peggiori in cui la produzione
limitata oppure per esempio quando le
castagne sono infestate da un parassita
e questo è dovuto anche in questo caso
ha problemi di cambiamento climatico i
castanicoltori sono comunque obbligati
hanno il compito di quirra il sottobosco
e in questo caso il materiale raccolto
viene bruciato in una conseguente
emissione di co2 nell'atmosfera
quello che abbiamo pensato
in questo caso è di ridare vita a questo
scatto quindi anziché bruciarlo
possiamo naturalmente riutilizzarlo in
danno di una nuova vita come vi
racconterò tra borgo se invece dalla
montagna del monte amiata ci spostiamo
in un posto altrettanto successivo
quindi verso il mare e caso la laguna di
orbetello
speriamo che anche qui troviamo delle
problematiche ambientali dovute alla
crescita incontrollata di agli
altrettanti soprattutto nelle stagioni
più calde che portano l'ecosistema
acquatico a soffrire di condizione di
atassia ciò la mancanza di ossigeno
neanche devono essere per questo
raccolte e trattate e amministrazioni
devono conferire in discarica come
rifiuti speciali con ulteriori costi per
la vocazione
ora siamo qui nei nostri laboratori di
ricerca dove gli scatti del territorio
di cui vi ho parlato in precedenza come
il riccio di castagna del monte amiata e
a vela
orbetello vengono sottoposte a una fase
di essiccazione
dopo di che vengono triturate e macinate
e soggette a una fase di estrazione
l'estrazione avviene con metodologia
completamente green cioè questo vuol
dire che non utilizziamo dei solventi
chimici
dopodiché viene fatta una
caratterizzazione funzionale e la sua
attività biologica br testata su di le
linee cellulari umane
il tratto viene opportunamente di lorito
e può essere così integrato all'interno
di prodotti secondari e terziari ad alto
valore aggiunto in questo caso abbiamo
per esempio proceduto a costituire delle
prototipi di treme in cui abbiamo i vari
tipi di estratti
le creme vengono sottoposte ad una fase
di analisi chimico biologica e vengono
qualche estate sulla contempo umana
in altri casi invece possiamo utilizzare
l'estratto come in questo caso ottenuto
dalle alghe della laguna di orbetello
direttamente sul campo
questo è un progetto in collaborazione
con un'azienda agricola del territorio
grossetano che ha testato il composto
direttamente
su dei pomodori in cui si è riversata un
aumento della produzione circa 30 per
cento e un anche un aumento della
qualità del frutto
grazie a un incremento della componente
zuccherina cosa facciamo poi con la
biomassa residua ottenuta dopo il
processo di registrazione non la
buttiamo ma la utilizziamo per esempio
per costruire della carta in questo caso
abbiamo dei prototipi di carta questo è
un prototipo di carta ottenuto
direttamente dalle alghe in questo caso
abbiamo un cartoncino ottenuto dal
riccio della castagna è l'ultimo esempio
è quello in cui abbiamo combinato i due
scarti per fornirci un foglio hai fatto
tenutosi ad allearvi che vernicia della
castagna